- Give it up for my band, y'all.
As I was saying, everybody.
(cheering)
I love...
Don't kill...
everybody.
That song was "Walkaway Joe,"
by Ms. Trisha Yearwood and Don Henley.
I love Trisha Yearwood, y'all.
Seriously, one of my favorite
singers on the planet.
Let's meet Matthew who
requested that song.
So where are you at, Matthew?
- It's Matthew McConaughey!
- Austin, Texas.
Hi there, Kelly.
- How are you doing?
- Relatively pretty well.
We're trying to get over
this freeze down here.
You know, it kinda knocked
some of us back a hair.
But well, overall we're doing pretty good.
- Yeah. Oh my God.
That's good to hear. That's good to hear.
Why did you request "Walkaway Joe?"
- Well, "Walkaway Joe."
And it was, think it was early 1992.
I'm going to college here
at the University of Texas.
This is before "Days and Confused."
And I was trying to get odd jobs
in front of the camera when I could.
And I got cast in that
music video to play Joe.
Things are going well then
where we end up the last stop
she wakes up and "Joe,"
myself, is nowhere to be seen.
Therefore, AKA the title, "Walkaway Joe."
- [Kelly] I love that
though. Do you remember?
I love that about country music videos,
especially in like the 90s,
there would be such a story,
like a plot.
Like, they'd have actors, real big actors.
And I think that's amazing.
I didn't know that was your first thing.
I didn't know that was
before "Dazed and Confused."
It's amazing.
- That, and "Unsolved Mysteries."
Yeah, "Walkaway Joe" was my first time
in front of the camera.
(laughing)
And I still don't believe
I've met Trisha in person.
- Did you just say that
and "Unsolved Mysteries?"
- [Matthew] Yes.
- I love you so much!
(laughing)
That's amazing.